hello everyone and welcome to a very
sharp tactical game from the 2005
Linares tournament it's round 12 and
it's Michael Adams with the white pieces
against the none other than a garika's
part of uh it's a remarkable game you
guys will enjoy it but before we check
out the actual game as this is um uh
kasparov's last tournament as an active
player this was played like on March 8
he retired uh or rather he announced his
retirement on on March 10. uh I thought
it'd be nice to have to check this one
out and some of you might not know but
he uh actually won the last event before
retirement uh but before we check out
the game a gentleman on Twitter uh
messaged me that he created this it's a
library or rather repository on GitHub
of all of the videos that I've created
and you can search through them much
more easily than you can on YouTube
because YouTube uh I don't know maybe a
year ago or two years ago
um uh well they made some sort of enough
date where you cannot search everything
the way you wanted to so the the
this creation by this gentleman allows
you to search all of my videos you can
search by a player name you can search
by opening you can sort by publish that
title player white player black you can
search by descending ascending for
example now at the moment it's um my
last video was this man plays Incredible
chess published on uh in 2003 as you can
see on the 11th of
um of uh February and if you if you
click ascending then it goes all the way
down to 2017 uh June so you can search
pretty much anything like you can write
here Magnus Carlson uh okay it already
offers a so Magnus Carlson let's say uh
scorch
Scorch game c44 Scotch game so you say
give me all the videos that I've made by
Magnus Carlsen where uh he played either
white or black in the scotch game or you
can specify uh that you want only where
he played white and where he played The
Scorch or black where he played The
Scorch so if you have a certain player
like you you're interested in um if
someone played the Sicilian Dragon maybe
you're interested if I have any videos
if Michael top played the Sicilian
dragon or if Bobby Fischer played uh the
neither for or something you can easily
search it here and okay there you have
it if we use these filters uh there are
five videos on my channel uh Magnus
Carlton versus Alexander now man and
Yani pomish versus Magnus Carlsen
Carlson versus Nakamura Carlson versus
carwana and Carlson versus Hikaru here
you can see Magnus having white pieces
in three of those games and uh uh black
pieces in two of those games and you can
also search by a filter by playing a
playing moves so you can just click here
filter by playing moves and I just okay
let's say E4 E5 Knight to F3 let's go
for some sort of a scotch here D4
captures captures and now let's say uh
let's say Bishop to C5 uh let's say
Bishop to E3 and let's say queen to F6
uh okay there aren't any games with this
particular move order uh but um uh for
example here uh up until this point uh
yeah you have like uh six games like you
have uh ding versus nepo uh World chair
Championship uh sort of a trailer that
I've made you you can watch that in it
from 2022 uh many games Max varmada
versus Anna Marie Mitch you remember the
xqc versus Charlie uh Legendary game of
course you'll you'll know that one uh so
it's a very very useful tool and you can
search quite a lot because I've made uh
I think now over 3 000 videos and if you
enjoy the way I present videos you can
easily search what you are interested in
I will put a link to this site in the
description below it's again matter
library.github.io so you can choose and
check everything for yourselves so
that's pretty much it what I wanted to
mention uh now let's check out the game
and yeah also sorry about not posting
any videos yesterday I
um I watched the Alexander volcanovski
versus uh Isla macachev fight and it was
really incredible like like five rounds
of grueling chess and I was you know I
watched interviews later and I've
watched what everyone else was saying
about the match so I really enjoyed it
that's why I didn't post any videos
yesterday if there are any fans of of
MMA what did you think about the fight
uh you know I'm very interested in
your opinion as well so do share that in
the comments now let's check out the
game so Michael Adams with the white
pieces opens with E4 uh we have pontus
E5 because parvo goes for his Sicilian
Defense so you know this is going to be
a good one Knight F3 D6 and open
Sicilian D4 characters captures with
Knight to F6 Knight to C3 and casparov
goes for the Knight of variation Ponte
A6 with Bishop to E3 the English attack
of course as Michael Adams is an
Englishman E6 with Bishop to E2 and now
uh Queen to C7 still to this day the
top move bishop t7 and queen to C7 are
the main lines uh Queen to D2 and now
Pawn to B5 uh probably we will have
castles on opposite sides of the board
so it makes sense to start the the flank
attack as early as possible so Pawn to a
three stopping B4 Bishop to B7 and now
Pawn to F3 defending that pawn and also
preparing g4h for G5 and so on so
Knights the C6 by Kasparov and here
Adam's just castles we have pawned the
B4 because Sparrow does not wait around
to see what happens on the king side
captures captures uh and now uh and
interestingly uh there is a game that
reached this exact same position only a
year after this game was played so in
2006 between uh Platt and the maxim
Lagarde where uh a capture some B4 was
not recaptured but rather Knight the B1
was played but here we have eight
characters on B4 and it is now as of
move 12 that this position has never
been repeated again so Knight chapters
on B4 by Gary we have Pawn to G4 and now
Bishop to E7 we have Pawn to G5 because
power of Shield is the Knight to D7 goes
to C5 uh Ponte H4 atoms continues his
attack on the king side and Kasparov
continues Shifting the attention to the
queen side Knight C5 with King to B1 uh
always a useful prophylactic move as
long as the the king is on C1 it's just
not a very very good spot I mean this
Knight the B3 at some point could be
very nasty so King to B1 and now Rook
the B8 now Kasparov uh puts the Rook on
the semi-open B file Ponte H5 and
Kasparov just castles not afraid of
those advancing pawns and Michael does
not mess around he goes for the
immediate Pawn to G6 as tal would say uh
to make the attack happen a little bit
uh just a little bit faster and he is
correct theory for example if you
capture just H6 and black is in huge
trouble here like a bishop F6 you could
capture on G7 Bishop captures with
Bishop H6 and already White's attack is
happening you're gonna capture here play
Queen to H6 and black is not surviving
this so instead after G6 with Bishop to
F6 and now uh Rook D to G1 beautifully
placed Rooks by atoms now uh Kasparov
has to be very very careful of what he
does next and he plays Bishop to A8 uh
this is a a surgically precise just
opening up that B file for The Rook uh
Bishop to G5 as this bishop is a very
strong attacking peace Focus power going
after that BT Pawn Adams of course wants
the eliminated but because power plays
Bishop to E5 saying that you can never
play F4 as then the four Pawn will hang
so what can atoms do here best for him
is Bishop to E3 and then you just
continue pressing on the king side but
he rushed it a little bit he played the
G captures on H7 with check because
Sparrow recaptured King captures on H7
and now Knight the B3 and here there's
just no going back from this here
kaspar's attack becomes Unstoppable and
this is how Kasparov starts at night
captures and see sorry Knight captures
on C2 eliminating the defender of the
Knight on B3 so Adams if he captures
then because power of just captures on
B3 not all that great he captures on C5
first but now Knight to A3 with check of
course the b-pawn cannot capture the B
Pawn is pinned King to A2 and now Queen
captures on C5 and now the problem is uh
if you capture here then the C3 Knight
is undefended for example captures
captures and you can pretty much resign
here so instead after Queen captures on
C5 Adams tried Knight to A4 and it seems
like uh he uh solved all of his problems
the queen will have to move you're gonna
win the Knight the Knight and queen
guard the B2 Pawn uh seems like
everything is perfectly fine but there
is one move and it's such a devastating
move that Kasparov can play uh feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
this incredible idea while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on always looking
for cool ways to sacrifice your queen
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is Knight to CQ now
the the the position uh changes
drastically because the queen no longer
guards the B2 pawn and if you capture
the black queen then Rook captures on B2
is mate in one the Knight here covers A1
and A3 the white King has no squares
left so here there's really nothing you
can do it's such a such a such a
devastating position that there's a
literally nothing you can do uh in the
game I think the B1 was played but even
if you play something like Rook to B1
let's say you just want to guard your
Pawn I hope good things might happen
even a rook captures on B2 is enough to
to just end the game Rook captures on B2
and now look at this queen to A3 with
check now you've removed the defender of
the A3 square and now after King to B1
just Rook the C8 or pretty much any move
uh uh we'll be winning here they're
they're just uh no nowhere for you to go
you're completely tied down uh this is
just a game Over The Rook can never
capture here otherwise a queen day one
will be Checkmate and you have zero
moves here there is nothing you can do
so in the game after Knight the C2 King
the B1 was played by Adams uh but here
because part of just played Queen to A3
and he was in this position on move 26
that Michael Adams resigned to the game
and a spectacular victory for Garrick as
part of with the black pieces in this
very strongly nice Tournament of 2005.
uh the reason uh you resign here is uh
well there's just no defense a rook
captures Knight captures Queen capture
Sun B2 will be Checkmate and if you
capture the Knight which of course you
can Rook F to C8 and that's it now the
queen has to go somewhere doesn't really
have a good Square you're gonna capture
on A4 and again Rook captures and B2 is
coming next there is no defense you
could try to prolong with Bishop to D1
uh but even just a bishop capture Sunny
for check it's uh the King has no
squares you're gonna have to capture
capture and then after you move the king
now you capture on B2 Rook captures
white will have to give up the queen and
okay you do have some pieces for the
queen but still uh for example after uh
King Captain we do queen to D3 and there
is no good way to stop Checkmate like
Rook to H2 or something just Rook to B8
check King to A2 now we're gonna play
Queen to B1 check run the white king up
the board Queen to A1 with check and
that's it Queen C3 checking a foreign
Queen before uh will be Checkmate so of
course Adams knows this after Queen A3
he resigned and uh as I've said a
brilliant victory for Kasparov with the
black pieces against the enemy
incredibly strong player and these are
the final standings of the tournament um
uh it was a a double round robin uh sort
of sharing uh first place uh Garrick as
foreign with eight out of 12 followed by
uh Anand with six and a half petroleko
with six Michael Adams with five and a
half
umejo with four and Jerusalem qasim John
of also with four points uh but uh even
though uh Kasparov was tied with topolov
and even though Kasparov lost his uh
encounter uh against Apollo it was it
was the final round of the tournament
and uh probably one of the reasons why
uh kasparo not the only reason of course
but one of the reasons Kasparov decided
to retire from chess is that he
shouldn't have lost that game and he he
still did and he said that okay that
that we cannot allow this it's time to
it it's time to retire but Kasparov won
the tournament because even though he
lost his encounter to topalovan they had
uh equal points because Parov had more
wins with the black pieces which was a
more important criteria at least for
this tournament
uh so yeah a little bit of a history
there hope you guys enjoyed that and
that you've seen uh how to attack with
the black pieces as I will uh once I
publish the video it will also be
searchable on that GitHub repository so
do use it if you have any
um games that you you uh maybe don't
know if I've covered and if you are
trying to suggest the game you can
always use hashtag suggestion for me to
to show a game you can first check if
I've already done maybe a video on that
game or maybe even if I have maybe it's
an older video like from 2018 uh maybe I
can do a remake on it if it was a really
bad video because I I do have those as
well uh so you know use it it's a it's a
brilliant Library uh hope it uh you know
comes in handy to you guys uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
I would like to wish a very happy
birthday to Magnus camp and I would like
to thank both your Cannon Fraser the
bakus and CDs for trade for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day